the other night you and I in honor of
Adam we worked on our thing for like two
weeks yes yes we did we sent scripts
back and forth yeah you had an
incredible like Jen had this idea that
we would sort of like see who you know
is closer to Adam that was the Christmas
tree and then we put these ornaments on
it and lit it up we just lit it up and
then we put some tinsel that's right
yeah and then up until the last minute
we were like rehearsing in the Monitor
and then we just went out there and
remember from across the stage and we
just walked out we were like all right
let's do that yeah yeah you know because
for two weeks we were like what about
this what about this what about that
what about that and when it came for
game time yeah we just we clicked you
guys locked like two puzzle pieces you
killed you two you get you did
comedy-wise you killed and then all of a
sudden we're in this room with like some
of the most extraordinary you know like
these comedy Legends Legends and we're
us
[Music]
yeah we uh stand ups enjoy those moments
you guys you guys kind of go we got to
do that we were nervous what is it like
doing stand-up because that is such an
unfamiliar world to me it's terrifying
it's terrifying like that night by the
way how about this Chris Rock went on oh
you're so good he did great he did oh he
killed and in my back of my head I was
like oh no my wife has to go after this
oh
yeah she loves you guys yeah we were
thrilled and yet not thrilled to follow
Jews
we're just like we're gonna pull it out
girl we're gonna do it and we did it
yeah yeah
um now I want to talk about murder
mystery too which I am so obsessed with
you guys
I not only love it but I loved the first
one so much I feel like I know you guys
like as the couple so I'm going in and
it's like you own it it's it's it's less
of an ensemble it's more focused it
sticks a landing that just I can't I
don't want to spoil anything true love
the ending
right yeah so do I so do we
absolutely that is what they call
sticking the land yes I didn't know that
term and I will now yeah yeah
it's still remained that Agatha Christie
perfect genre of who did it all the
satisfaction layer upon layer of mil
foyer of delights and I just I really I
feel foyer of delights are you writing
this down yeah I just come on man I'm
gonna get my stepping up I mean you guys
did Just Go With It did you know then
that you wanted to keep working together
yes yes yes yes yes we had so much fun
yeah which is great when you get to go
to work and laugh a lot exactly and then
you you you get at the end of you know
you have this wonderful experience and
then hopefully we get provide some
comedy and relief and Escape for the for
the audience yeah and everybody has a
good time
Etc
yeah
feels like it's about 20 or 30 minutes
long it goes by lightning fast the pace
is perfection it's like you just you are
left wanting so much more and then with
that amazing ending you're just like now
you shot the first one in Italy yes is
it true you went and had pizza with the
clooneys oh yeah I did that was great we
did yes yes that was amazing yes wait
look what he wore
sorry
look at the bus
yeah those are
satin blue dark blue with white piping
basketball shorts well and a velor
turquoise it's it was very comfortable a
little warm and little but when I eat
pizza I wear shorts I got nobody else in
the damn world do you think I did for a
wrap gift on that movie by him a
wardrobe or like a Garanimals kind of a
wardrobe I said to Jackie what what can
I do to help you
so we got a couple we've got a couple
shirts couple pairs of pants I wore them
in the house did you in the house yeah I
put them on I wore all everything you
guys have I use both these girls get me
amazing gifts throughout my entire uh
career and by that and I I use it at
least once you're I mean I this is very
dressed up for you you're in a full
corduroy pant that's like a tuxedo I
gotta tell you the truth don't don't
judge me these pants are they're called
Lucky Brand and I think I've had these
for 18 years because they fit do they
say lucky you when you open them
that's what they used to say remember
really on the cross no they would say it
on the zipper with the right when you
opened it it said lucky you lucky so I
guess whoever got in there was lucky you
yeah yeah yeah appreciate everything you
realize that there is a like a movement
like the biggest craze for all the kids
now up into their teens 20s 30s is
Sandler core it's a thing now it is
furnace
yeah yeah yeah
I like the moccasin in the middle yeah
Marcus institute and matches and then
you've got the the the ankle high calf
sock always white oh yeah yeah there's a
oh I see right now and those pictures
are a lot of different weights
you and I always talk about that we're
major fluctuates yeah about 30 30 pound
fluctuation I girl out with you so hard
we always talk about our bodies yeah how
you doing today fat how you doing today
skinny yeah how you doing today midnight
that's honestly that's the beauty of
these pants they always make me feel
just fine
I mean what is the number one item that
one needs to rock the ever so important
fashionista movement of Sandler Court I
need it from the horse's mouth
foreign